Today I wanna talk about learning slowly.
You know, we read so much about learning
the language in three months or in six
months, and books that promise you you'll
be fluent when you finish the book.
And of course, we all
know that that's not true.
And I think I suddenly realized, you
know, as I was walking to a place
that we had been to before, first time
we went there, we were in a hurry.
We didn't notice anything.
Uh, it was going to the old town, but the
second time we were walking more slowly.
We didn't care when we got there, but
we were enjoying the surroundings.
We noticed more things, and I think
the same is true in language learning.
I showed LingQ to my cousin in Sweden
and right away he was so impatient.
Uh, you know, he clicked on a
word, saw the meaning, and he
said, well, how do I remember that?
How will I be able to
use it when I need it?
And I said, don't worry about it.
Just take it easy.
Just relax.
Let the language come in.
Don't be in a hurry.
Don't be impatient.
If you're impatient.
If you try overly hard to learn
something, chances are you won't learn.
We have to have an attitude...
the same attitude that I had when
I was walking slowly of noticing
things because we're not in a hurry.
That really...
I apologize for the noise in
the background, who we are in
the breakfast area of our hotel.
Very relaxing place.
Again, relaxing is good.
I think pressure in language
learning is bad for us.
I think we have to learn to learn slowly.
Just as there was a very famous book
written about, you know, eating slowly
and, and living slowly and encouraging
people to step back from the rat race.
I think this has real application for
language learning and um, of course there
are different ways that you can relax.
You can relax even doing the mini
stories at LingQ, the sort of repetitive
listening is almost addictive.
It's a bit like Zhuangzi's parable
of the butcher where he does the
same motion over and over again, and
therefore he achieved perfection through
repetition, not because he read some
rules, grammar rules or instructions,
but because he practiced it over and
over again, and that slow repetition
is important, but by the same token, we
can listen to interesting things, not
worried about what we understand, what
we retain, and just enjoy the language.
I think there's a lot to be said
for slow learning without pressure.
Now this is gonna upset some people
in school where they feel if something
was taught, therefore the person, the
student, should be able to repeat it.
Uh, parents and administrators
want exams and tests and test
results and grading, but all of
this is putting pressure on people.
Instead, what we want is a, an approach
of slow enjoyment of the language.
The end result will be better learning,
better learning, because the pressure
to achieve something in a hurry in fact
prevents us from gradually assimilating
the language because after all, through
our slow and gradual listening and
reading, we are depositing sort of
thin layers of the language on our
brain slowly without realizing it.
And all of a sudden we're
building up this familiarity in
this capability in the language.
All of that is achieved
through slow learning.
So my message today, even though tomorrow
we're taking a high speed train to
Krokow, but today I want to talk about
slow, slow learning for more enjoyable
learning and more effective learning.
Thank you for listening.
Bye.
And we're gonna cross the waterway again.
And of course there's a separate crossing
for the cyclists, which are many, and
we're gonna go on the pedestrian area.
One other impression here in
Copenhagen is just the variety
of languages that you hear.
Mostly European, not many
Americans, not many from Asia, some.
Lots of Brazilians and people from
all over Europe and similarly, the
staff everywhere, you come across
people whose native language is
Spanish, is French people from
Switzerland, south America, Poland.
It's a real hodgepodge of languages.
Everybody gets along very well
together and uh, yeah, interesting.
Here we have people on the
water enjoying the day.
It's, it's extraordinary.
That was the, uh, theater
again, those modern buildings.
You know, and everywhere people
are sitting and enjoying the
sunshine, enjoying a beer, which
is something we're gonna do.
So it's uh, our last day in Denmark.
And just to update you on my
struggles with different languages,
so yesterday here in Copenhagen,
we had a Farsi speaking taxi driver
and an Arabic speaking taxi driver.
Struggled to say anything
in either language.
Better in Farsi.
I kept thinking Polish, even Korean.
The other day, we had, uh, we
met a couple who were Swiss and
the wife was from Korea, and I
actually did better in Korean.
I think the issue there is that you
can work on languages, get them to
a certain level, but if they aren't
good enough, you're not gonna be able
to hold onto them in every situation.
There are gonna be
situations when you struggle.
You're confused.
It, it really doesn't matter.
Everything I put into those languages,
I'll go back there and get them back.
But in the short run, it's
a little frustrating that...
and I've had this happen to me before.
I remember eight years ago I was in,
uh, Bratislava at a language conference,
and I had spent six months on Ukrainian.
And my Ukrainian wasn't bad.
But before the conference in
Bratislava, I spent two weeks
trying to get some Slovak going.
Slovak, very similar to Czeck.
And I was able to speak Slovak in
the shopping center and so forth
in Bratislava, but at the language
conference, there was a Ukrainian
guy there and the well was dry.
There is no way I could get any
Ukrainian to come out because everything
had been plugged up with Slovak.
And at times even, you know, Korean
or something else would come in.
So the brain controls
how quickly you learn.
The brain controls what you
can remember at any given time.
But if you fill your brain with
all these languages, with the right
opportunity, if you get lo a chance
to speak, it'll start coming back.
So I never get frustrated.
I mean, I get frustrated, but I'm not
upset that I can't remember 'cause I'm
always gonna struggle until I, I bring
those languages to a sufficient level,
which is not the case for, you know,
my Iranian or my Arabic or so forth.
Anyway, that's last day in Denmark.
We're going off to Sweden and then,
uh, thereafter we go back to Poland
and I'm gonna really work on getting
my Polish up, even though I may not
be able to hold onto it for that long.